my god you're sweating no that 357 hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions even hotter wings and today
I'm joined by Bryan Cranston and James
Franco together they started why him
which is gonna be in theaters December
23rd guys welcome to the show thank you
beer and Bryan I think you might have a
bit of a competitive advantage because
the New Mexico roots it's not just about
breaking bad is it it's about the hot
chilies right you like the hot chilies
Chili's down there the green Chili's
damn Chili's as they would say James are
you without foreign uh I'm terrible with
that that's the fun most important thing
is what's the prize whoever Wow a
30-second plug we really extend for you
on the show great you ready to get it
started sure
[Music]
all right so this first one is sriracha
sriracha not ideal why him it tells a
holiday tale as old as time you have a
father
and you have a boyfriend and they're in
conflict over somebody that they love
for very different reasons and there's
some people who are great at appealing
to dads and there are some people like
me who make horrible first impressions
do you guys have any advice for how to
win over the scary dad yeah
don't try it's just not gonna work I
mean I've been there before and I never
understood why the dads didn't like me
the mothers would right you bring them
some flowers or something you there's
nothing you could bring the dad that
would make him go okay come here
he's not going to like you there's
nothing you can do so don't try if you
back off a little bit he understands
that you allow that space between you as
opposed to you trying to reach in when
that's the worst thing you can do good
advice from the man over here uh if
you're a movie you don't even have to
win over dad I feel like they have to
win over you think like painting just
grabbing by the movie star let's go up
and grandmother that's what he can do we
all know that now easy
this one is the hot one sauce you're on
the hot one show okay this is this is
your own shows this is it it's at all
this is it hot one there are a lot of
theories why men grow facial hair and
over the courses of your guys career
you've run the gamut from sexy stubble
to full-blown pirate beards so what I
want to do is show you some iconic
facial hair moments and your guys career
maybe you guys can trade grooming
secrets beard pet peeves the mustaches
that you miss the beards that you
couldn't stand I just want to get a snap
reaction you ready we've had our fair
share of facial hair I don't know what
was it like to have the most famous
goatee in the world
well it's badass is what it really is
and there's you know there's a certain
of our facial hair when I first started
Walter White
I wanted it what I called an impotent
mustache okay which was thin and nothing
past the corners of the of the mouth
okay anytime
facial hair drops past the corners of
the mouth
you start getting badass the Heisenberg
notice Brian always has great facial
expressions when he's sporting his beard
this is like the 127 hours era and then
we have like a 2016 sort of era yeah
what should you remember more fondly I'm
not I just mustaches I don't know I I
mean though they're both for roles the
first one was actually for my thesis
film I played a poet named Hart Crane
who had a stache and then this is for my
70s look I don't know I am I'll sport it
but if I don't have to sew like this
this is the elegantly disheveled look
yeah
as you can see Brian grows a much better
beard than again that's about the extent
of my beard growth so what doesn't your
easy what's not it's not growing in the
nest doesn't go it doesn't go in the
middle it's just
I don't know so you've got the beatnik
kind of chin beard I don't know if it's
like late my grandmother has a beard has
sweetie yeah no she's Swedish I don't
know if that so her beard is blonde the
game changes quite a bit as we go to
pain 100% not in its construct just in
its violence and the violence yes
violence factor is called pain okay okay
so you know James too bad so far I'm
waiting for it to kick in better kick in
I think of all but maybe you just missed
it James maybe you just missed it no
problem we'd like to talk to food on
first we feast and James I know you used
to work the night shift at a McDonald's
drive-through and the social media age
has really pulled back the curtain it's
fun what that's like
but what are your fondest memories of
that time when you're working the
McDonald's drive-through the night shift
it was an adventure you know um I I was
a young actor do different accents in
practice different accents some people I
got a hot I got a couple dates uh yeah
hey oh yeah that's not even easy pull
from the drives I know in that and for
whatever reason at the time we had to
wear like purple McDonald's hats it was
it was hard to get a date with that
thing on but uh I managed to do it I
remember I took a young lady to Titanic
Wow
we went back to McDonald's parking lot
and made out and I'm Brian you have some
bizarre kitchen experience as well your
job at a Daytona Beach restaurant huh
actually got you
wrapped up in a murder investigation
yeah there was I worked at a Polynesian
restaurant while I was traveling around
the country and got job as a waiter and
there was a guy at this the chef at this
restaurant named Peter Wong yo thought
you got away Peter Wong was a miserable
human being just an awful despicable
hated everyone kind of guy and everyone
hated him so the waiters would sit
around and talk about how we how would
you kill Peter Wong so I said I think
I'd slice them up in a wok and stir-fry
him and make Moo goo gai Peter so the
end of the season comes my brother and I
hop on our motorcycles and we take off
we're gonna be gone for three four or
five months about the time we left
something happened to Peter he
disappeared the cops came into the
restaurant and said is there anybody
here who ever talked about hurting Peter
Wong and they're like yeah kind of all
of us but anybody who's not here anymore
the Cranston boys where are they they've
took a denim over sign or motor sign
when did they leave a week ago that's
just around the time he disappeared they
put out an APB on us to look for us on
our motorcycles we're probably in the
Carolinas by then earth
further north and because Peter Wong who
always carried a huge stash of cash just
to compensate for his yeah he was a
horrible person anyway a hooker picked
him up at a at a dog track in in Daytona
and brought it lured him home some other
guy clubbed him on the head they shoved
him in the trunk of a car and that's
where he's dead now he was dead and they
were looking for us because we were
talking about how were you at the
honestly how we were yes I willed it I
was 20 21 and yeah and then every date
catch me and this one is Mad Dog 357 how
are you doing James brian is obviously
just cool as a cucumber Mad Dog 357 as a
key like not get on your lips there's no
real work around this game I'm just
gonna call it bass baby oh hi this is a
part that we do in every show where we
do explain that Graham we do a deep dive
on our guests Instagram and we pull up
interesting pictures
and because James uploads at a rate
that's like a hundred times you Brian
what we've done is we've pulled up just
a couple of James's pictures and what I
want to do is show you Brian and you try
to fill in the blanks you tell me what's
going on in these pictures and then
James you can tell Brian to what extent
he has the story right does that sound
good
mm-hmm like it's gonna be embarrassing
I'll do right off the bat yeah that's
awesome
you know that's funny because I
recognize that from the movie that's
actually not Photoshop that's his actual
body really got a trunk like that hi
James yeah I'm hard on that presents a
member what is this I didn't make that I
didn't Photoshop that I didn't put those
two images together I just found it
that's a salt and pepper shakers
evidence boom what's going on going on
here is that unique yeah Wow
you just got shot or something right
what no I'm playing you oh that's you
yeah oh wow that's awesome
yeah oh now I get it Wow when did you do
that that is um my emmy-nominated web
series I'm making a scene and we mash up
different TV shows we don't and we don't
choose what gets matched up
my god your sweat no that was uh that
357 so uh like a wheel with the fans
pick which shows we're gonna recreate
and then we have a wheel and the wheel
decides what shows you can be matched up
so breaking bad got matched up with Sex
in the City
it's alright I guess yeah I got one more
for you you know what's going on here no
I don't want to know what upset is that
Seth I couldn't even tell but there's
love there ma'am
yeah well obviously you haven't seen our
recreation of the Kanye and Kim video
bound to know we recreated it
shot-for-shot and he played Kim and I
played Kanye and are you guys did you
guys find each other are you a couple
now
after that yeah yeah made it over
there's never going back
[Music]
okay we have one more I need LaRose we
have one more James taking out entire
glass of milk already Brian how you
doing
I'm okay there was a period of time when
that mad dog just kind of went wow
that's what it does grabbed me and
pulled me forward like woo
but now you've recovered now I'm okay
alright so this one is Blair's Megadeth
sauce with liquid rage you're probably
wondering why is he grabbing the bottle
why is he shaking it up like that and
the reason is because it's sort of a
tradition around here to put a little
extra dab on the last wing you don't
have to if you don't want to I put it
like a little down that's aggressive you
don't have to if you don't want to put
it in the middle of table don't have to
well okay a little bit extra oh what a
DAB well it's slow no no no like that
that's good that's good oh oh oh that's
it
let's good just a little just a little
dab in a scrape that's no big deal there
we go it specifically always watching
okay there we go
all right boys god bless you and you're
doing it right with us right you're like
right along with you all right and so
are you immune to this now so I've now
done it like 42 times yeah so it's just
I know it's Groundhog Day I'm just as
blasted out just in as much pain as you
guys are it's just this is my existence
this is my life I just but maybe that
I'm working on it yeah all right bite
the part that's not worth it
it's you know what all right hey all
right
so we're focusing on James on this once
I know your dimes
I got a deal fast I think my stomach's
gonna like rebel but I got it out fast I
think we do a c-plus job here on hot
ones but that doesn't matter because
Dave Skylark gives the hottest
interviews in the entire game well
Dave's garlics from the interview that
was a sad because we were gonna use that
guy we're gonna had a whole run with you
know video game movies back yeah whole
thing too bad I guess it's just we just
can't bring him back you can't bring
about nobody was is to bring that back
we use the character I interviewed Nicki
Minaj and he is hell yeah oh the VMAs
yeah it was I mean it was brave I think
you could actually bring that character
back there's no reason you can't yeah
it's ballsy ballsy and it's good and we
need interviewers if this is all we got
we better it was far north of
interviewers yes look at you guys
clearing the board heroic brave how do
you feel alive I feel even closer to
Brian after God the floor is now indoors
this camera that camera are that camera
thirty seconds let the people know what
you have going on in your life oh this
is what we win
Brian has a new book I can't wait to
read it
he didn't get me a copy yet oh god I
keep hearing about this yeah I have a
book of the book out called a life in
parts and it's about all the parts that
we play in our real lives father a son
husband you know brother and all the
parts that that I've played on film on
television it's come I got some movies
coming out next year I did a movie
called the masterpiece with my brother
which is that about the making of a
really good bad movie called the room
have you seen the room it's supposed to
be the worst movie ever made
yeah yeah and Brian actually plays
himself in the in the movie James has a
habit of roping friends in
[Music]
I don't like when you hit me in the
balls